peu
[Musique]
pour ces gamins mendier est devenu un
métier tous les jours ils quadrillent la
gare du nord sous la surveillance des
adultes qui les accompagnent victime
d'une exploitation intolérable ou
simplement d'un mode de vie différent du
nôtre
ces jeunes mendiants dérange forcément
dans un pays où l'école est obligatoire
fils et filles du vent roms tsiganes de
roumanie ils ne connaissent que la rouge
et la manche rosa irina sont arides en
france il ya cinq ans avec la famille
les années d'errance à travers la
banlieue parisienne de nanterre à
saint-ouen en passant par gennevilliers
c'est avec ma marque et geof première
fois faire l'amour avec mon père herrina
faisait la manche avec ma mère et moi il
faisait l'amour avec mon père est maçon
grogne fait c'est du sol la manche n'est
pas un champ de l'elysée refusé à kerfot
à au chaud avec les galères 3 s'offre au
cateau faut pas mal de tout impôt parce
pris à trois ou à 11 et 13 ans rosa et
irina sont à présent en âge de faire la
manche seules elles passent toute leur
nuit sur les champs elysées et gagne une
centaine de francs par soir un père
reparti en roumanie une mer sans travail
toute l'économie de la famille reposent
sur la pitié des passants
fait peau neuve pour l'ajouter borges
ercis
m
je suis dit mon flair d'un du viala des
français bien ses distances et à berck
était au budget dans la bouche mais
c'est pas vrai il croise à luc romero
tout cas se parler et a obligé vers la
bouche je te prie pas la bouche tu vas
tu vas mourir de faim de soif
leurs nuits s'organise toujours de la
même façon les deux soeurs change
régulièrement d'endroit pour éviter la
police et les autres mendiants elle ce
poste ensuite à la sortie des cabarets
et des boîtes de nuit jusqu'à 5 heures
du matin elles dorment sur une bouche
d'aération qui évacue de l'air chaud
quelques heures de repos avant de
prendre le premier métro qui les
ramènera à leurs caravanes
[Applaudissements]
je crois que s'il est bien je crois que
s'il fait tous mes tempes aille bien
pour les enfants ici peut-être était pas
bien que la roumanie
ici la même comme la roumanie communiste
comment j'ai fait comme ça gemma teller
une militante s'il vous plaît un plan
pour acheter manger l'argent par les
gardes
beaucoup de gens pas messieurs dames
s'il vous plaît sur cet ancien parking
près de 400 personnes ont élu domicile
sans autorisation en région parisienne
environ trois mille roms régulièrement
expulsés par les municipalités traînent
leurs caravanes d'un terrain salue pas
un autre sédentarisés de force où le
régime communiste de nombreux roms ont
repris la route au début des années 90
pour fuir un pays où plus de 50 % de la
population vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
il traverse l'europe toujours par des
filières clandestines pour venir soit on
a un véhicule ne se débrouillent donc on
est déjà un petit peu plus riches soit
on n'a rien et on passe par un passeur
quelqu'un qui va vous enfermer dans une
une camionnette et vous faire passer la
frontière de nuit etc et ça ça se paye
ça s'organise pas ici un peu comme une
agence de voyages alors qui peut se
payer soit en argent directement au
départ parce qu'on aura laissé s'est
bien vendu ces biens soient en argent
après coup et là on vous regardera le
passeport ou les documents essentiels et
il faudra se débrouiller pour gagner
très vite par la mendicité ou toute
autre forme gagner très vite les sommes
à rembourser une fois arrivés en france
il faut une adresse postale pour pouvoir
déposer une demande d'asile
à nanterre une association offre une
domiciliation gratuite et une aide pour
toutes les démarches administratives
mais depuis la fin de la dictature de
ceausescu les roms n'ont plus le statut
de réfugié politique
déboutés du droit d'asile ils deviennent
très vite des sans papiers un certain
nombre d'entre eux ont été expulsés par
les forces de l'ordre et selon les
en application de la loi simplement la
majorité d'entre eux sont revenus en 93
pasqua étant alors ni de l'intérieur il
avait mis en place à une tentative de
prouver des de retour ils ont empoché
les deux autos et se retourner là bas et
trois semaines après il était à nouveau
sur les terrains on les envoyait à la
permanence de la chaze les roms font
souvent de nouvelles demandes d'asile
sous un autre nom
ils peuvent ainsi rester en france
encore plusieurs mois et gagne plus
d'argent que pendant dix ans passés au
pays
on est dans ses circuits de débrouille
la mendicité débrouiller base c'est de
partir le matin aussi commandant les
boulots simplement de malda protéines
rues pour chercher de l'argent quand on
n'a pas de chez soi à son enfant la mère
avec soin et quand en plus on sait que
la présence d'un enfant est un élément
qui va apitoyer davantage est pas aussi
on gardera son enfant son enfant dans
les bras
[Musique]
m
une véritable économie parallèle
s'organise sur les campements des
familles vivent de la manche de
récupération travail au noir ou larcins
et à l'intérieur de la communauté tout
se monnaie certains vont chercher l'eau
d'autres tractent les caravanes avec la
voiture en cas d'expulsion
[Musique]
une tribu avec ses règles propres guidé
par un chef un protecteur qui se fait
rétribuer ses services
[Musique]
j'ai mené la crau comme le dirait la
grille qui devait d'essence et marche
avec sous ses pas qu'on s'appelle tout
le monde y perd 5,7 faut si frau pour la
sauce est il dans des coques de vous
restituer tous bords
alors et vous permet taxi nation car les
carnets vaccination de vaccins faudrait
aller les chercher là où on en est toi
tu es daniela et toi voilà alors tu l'as
eu comme une fois par semaine la mission
banlieue de médecins du monde envoie une
équipe sur les camps pour leur apporter
les premiers soins et éventuellement les
orienter vers les services d tard cette
année
quand elle aura l'aide médicale ont valu
préparé une lettre et prendre un rendez
vous pour faire l'examen complet à
l'hôpital infections respiratoires
épidémie de gale ou plaie mal soignées
sont le lot quotidien de ces familles
qui vivent dans des conditions
déplorables
pas d'eau courante de chauffage de
sanitaires ni de bennes à ordures la vie
de ces roms semble appartenir à une
autre époque
je dirais qu'on trouve pas dans nos
campagnes les enfants participent l
économie familiale il ya peut-être
encore des enfants qui vont conduire les
troupeaux traire les vaches
il participe à l'économie familiale les
ait plus d'enfants ici c'est pareil
la mendicité n'est plus interdite par la
loi depuis 94
en revanche la provocation des mineurs à
la mendicité sévèrement punis uniquement
si la remise d'argent un adulte est un
fait établi
les policiers du 1er arrondissement ont
déjà procédé à plusieurs arrestations en
flagrant délit après des mois de
surveillance des familles roumaines
vous avez un article du code pénal
l'article 227 val qui prévoit les peines
applicables
la provocation de mineur la modicité
quelles sont ses peines la peine est
près de deux ans d'emprisonnement et de
300 mille francs d'amendé
et lorsque le mineur est âgée de moins
de 15 ans la peine est aggravée la main
devient 500 mille francs
mille trois cent mille et puis
l'emprisonnement passe à 3 ans ne sont
pas des belles négligeable
on va interpeller mère et enfant on ne
note pas là tranquillement ou la
troisième
[Musique]
il peut être placé en garde à vue la
quantité de l'heure de votre
interpellation
c'est à dire 17h m'avez compris on verra
ça au stade les adultes sont
généralement condamnés à plusieurs mois
de prison avec sursis
les enfants sont placés en foyer mais ne
sont pas séparer définitivement de leurs
parents
pour que le judiciaire interviennent et
juge des enfants
il faut que les parents exercent de
façon tout à fait car ans et l'autorité
parentale
je sois par des mauvais traitements soit
par des des conduites qui met ses
enfants en danger
donc là il a apprécié savoir si ces
enfants sans réellement en danger
souvent d'ailleurs les parents que nous
rencontrons sont chaleureux s'en occupe
correctement les enfants sont nourris
suivi le problème c'est que vous avez là
affaire à une population qui a des
références culturelles et des références
de fonctionnement tout à fait autres que
les nôtres et qui se trouve un peu à la
limite de l'état de droit
[Musique]
au delà de la répression qui vit surtout
intimider les parents la meilleure
solution pour empêcher le travail des
enfants et de les scolariser mais là
encore la plupart des expériences
tentées dans ce domaine ont échoué sur
la réussite scolarisés 5/10 peut-être
pendant une période extrêmement courte
c'est le maximum et pourquoi parce que
les municipalités refusent de les
scolariser alors que la loi dit
clairement sens sans ambiguïté que quel
que soit le statut des parents les
enfants présents sur le territoire
français doivent être normalement
scolarisés
pour rosa irina l'occident n'a pas tenu
ses promesses
elle envisage de rentrées avec leur mère
en roumanie rejoindre le reste de la
famille toi et tous les jours auprès de
l'ot fallait pas les corps restait plus
qu on va faire la bombe pas très bien
[Musique]
la misère peut-elle justifier la
mendicité des enfants rose a en tout cas
rêve d'une autre en france
[Musique]